[Music]
Dan Schneider update thank you choosy
Dan Schneider update
for real Dan Schneider update
what are you doing here today
what's your what do you want to get
accomplished well that's uh Alexa
Nicholas remember we've covered her many
years ago oh [ __ ] yeah well I want to
make Nick safe for kids because in my
personal experience working on Zoe 101
um didn't feel safe um I didn't feel
like Nickelodeon was protecting me or
had my best interest in mind and so
after hearing so many different stories
from different next Stars it just feels
like enough is enough and so we're here
today trying to make a change in
Nickelodeon
triggering did he hear a Nickelodeon
today I didn't even sleep last night
um but I mean I think anyone is did Dan
Snyder molest you that's all I care
about I mean yes anybody gonna say
anything I know people everyone's saying
like oh but this is rough I get it but
it's been five years okay we're gonna
stop this guy are we not yes no maybe
let's go I mean because if we're not
then we need to drop it right so because
look
if you guys aren't gonna [ __ ] say it
by what can we do you know
all we get those [ __ ] allegations if
every time you're asked you play Coy
like Jeanette McCurdy did like what is
that going to help you know
like oh it was a Creator okay but like
were you gonna no I won't say his name
yeah it's like you want us to get you
want us to do something about this
murder problem but you don't want us to
tell you don't want to tell us who the
murderer is yeah I need to know you know
so we put the murderer away I think the
murders will stop trust me when I tell
you no nobody nobody wants this guy to
[ __ ] go down more than me but at this
point do you guys gotta [ __ ] or get off
the pot here what are they worried about
at this point it's not ndas because
Jeanette McCurdy remember she said that
she didn't [ __ ] take the money she
admitted she didn't take the money
so what's keeping these people you know
did he not do anything then because I'm
not saying that I think he did but I'm
just saying at this point you know you
think one person would have come out by
now right
because Jeanette and all of us deserve
an apology
we really do what do you want to see
from Nick Nickelodeon going forward
um well I definitely don't want to hear
one more story of a big star having a
traumatic experience that's for sure I
want no more ndas that's pretty much
what you proud we're done with ndas no
more silencing in there we want to know
what's happening in there so we can
actually help if needed yeah we can't
participate in any type of help if we
don't know what's going on in there and
all these corporations keep silencing
people with mdas
can I be honest sure I usually just
cannot stand
like female actress types that are like
protesting and I want because they
always have these like [ __ ] empty
[ __ ] sentiments
ulterior motives yes I kind of like this
chick man yeah yeah she's not she's not
like I mean okay yeah she's not naming
names but I'll give her credit for not
going we wanna you know Empower women
and we want to do to change the
corporate culture and create Synergy but
like she's literally going no more
[ __ ] ndas this is [ __ ] you can't
[ __ ] help people if they don't know
what the [ __ ] going on in there
enough's enough no more with the [ __ ]
ndas and let's have some oversight
you're like oh so you actually showed up
with points to make you know what actual
Solutions not just like oh I don't know
we could be good to kids you know you
know what I did notice
someone's holding the foot Nickelodeon
sign back there too and we all know what
that's a reference doing and apologize
to all the Nick stars that suffered in
any
childhood
try would like them to take
accountability and say they're sorry I
think that's yeah like let me tell you
working with Dan Schneider was so bad
that you Keenan thinks he's a real black
guy now so it's [ __ ] getting really
weird okay yeah I don't use that word
King he's saying that to Mike Tyson yeah
I really Mike I suggest you stop using
that word yeah okay but like I mean what
the [ __ ] you gonna do about it you're
like all right good point are you six
I'm 60 years old and I could still kill
everybody in this room aren't you the
one that like Aaron Soto no man that was
kale
laughs
simple and we shouldn't have to beg for
that in any way you know yeah we deserve
an apology and why not just give it to
us because Chris Matthews said because
the reason they're not giving you an
apology because it opens too yeah
massive litigation I wanted to like sort
of mediate the situation is there any
hope for you and Jamie Lynn to sort of
no chance no chance I'm I'm trying to
move on I mean obviously I'm here in
front of Nickelodeon I started to eat
Predators movement and it felt like if I
didn't come here that I was really
overstepping a huge part of my own
trauma yeah um and so I felt like okay I
have to come here and face my childhood
trauma once and for all and then kind of
leave this behind right but I'm like
just ready to to move on you know
I get that everyone wants to sell their
books and have other pet projects
but why don't we just like you know get
the ball rolling it's been five years
bro since we've started covering this
five [ __ ] years
and nothing's gonna [ __ ] happen of
course you know of course we know
nothing's gonna [ __ ] happen what are
we crazy